[Music]
Republican candidates looking to
capitalize on their big moments from the
slugfest in Milwaukee eight presidential
hopefuls clashing in the first
Republican debate going Toe to Toe over
the key issues voters care about as they
look for a boost in the polls
I will never let the Deep State
bureaucrats lock you down I'm the only
person on the stage who isn't bought and
paid for so I can say this the climate
change agenda
I was a house conservative leader before
it was cool Margaret Thatcher said if
you want something said ask a man if you
want something done ask a woman I'm the
only one on this stage who's ever beaten
the Democratic incumbent election
America can do for anyone what she's
done for me our nation is in trouble and
it's in trouble because of failed
leadership and the solution is not four
more years of Joseph Biden I'm from a
town of 300 people it's a big deal to
make it on the stage but there's one
candidate standing out Vivek Rama Swami
grabbing a lot of the headlines and the
attention of his fellow debaters
let me just address a question that is
on everybody's mind at home tonight
who the heck is this skinny guy with a
funny last name and what the heck is he
doing in the middle of this debate stage
I've had enough already tonight of a guy
who sounds like Chachi BT standing up
here the last person in one of these
debates Brett who stood in the middle of
the stage and said what's a skinny guy
with an odd last name doing up here was
Barack Obama and I'm afraid we're
dealing with the same type of amateur
now is not the time for on-the-job
training the reality is that today today
Ukraine is not a priority for the United
States of America I wish you well in
your future career on the boards of
Lockheed and Raytheon
there you have it you're watching so the
reality you have no foreign policy
experience
and the reviews are in from the liberal
media
you'll never guess it but I think they
didn't like it very much
I think DeSantis was absolutely terrible
I really thought that like he was
performing and forgive me at kind of a
Doug burgum level it was all
it was also miserable the public got
treated to a whole heap of crazy Vivek
is like I said Annoying he was intrusive
he was disrespectful he was
conspiratorial he was obnoxious at times
yeah it's just really ashamed to see how
far the Republican party has come begin
with
um Judge Jeanine hero
you've been talking to everybody about
your thoughts tell us what you thought
about last night first of all I loved it
I absolutely loved it I was glued to the
television and read 10 and Stella were
two for a while until they finished
their biscuits listen I I mean I love
democracy in action and you know to me
it was like talking to a jury right the
American people are the jury these
people are the lawyers trying to sell
themselves to the American people I
thought Vivek he was the populist guy
who was the non-politician in business
like Donald Trump who was the first one
to say even if Donald Trump is convicted
I'll go for it even though they all
swore that they would support him and
everybody is like looking at everybody
else to try to figure that out I was
impressed with Nikki Haley I have to
tell you I was very impressed with Nikki
she has a lot of foreign policy
experience and she showed it I heard
someone on Fox this morning and I was
very disturbed by it for a couple hours
actually it bothered me the individual
said you know Nikki Haley la Foster cool
she was yelling at the bank there was
real resentment and I said to myself why
is he picking on the woman when the men
were all yelling at each other as well I
mean that that was very offensive and I
wonder how many Americans thought that
and with respect to DeSantis
he I was happy with what he said but
it's just awkward he had like this
awkward smile whenever he finished you
know it was like he didn't know what he
should do like taking his fifth grade
picture
um and then Chris Christie I mean he he
was a bulldog I think there were some
things that he said you know they were
not total anti-trump where he tried to
actually it seemed like he wanted to be
in the race as opposed to just being
anti-trumper uh and finally uh Pence it
was out of character uh for him to say
some of the things that he said but
Trump was talking about yesterday
and uh I I mean Pence was talking about
yesterday and it really didn't matter so
to me the winners were Vivek Nikki Haley
and uh DeSantis who I think probably
made some ground up but the one thing
that I loved that I cheered about was
when Vivek got up and he said drill
frack and burn coal and make us energy
independent again and he connected it to
the economy and that was the most
important connection I thought that was
a nice clean and concise line uh Greg
what was your big takeaway from last
night well I think the the big Winners
today were I mean from last night were
Brett Baer and Martha McCallum yes I
have that in my notes too did you oh I
beat you to it that's why I told you to
come to me before her but they did it
they had to put they had to put up with
a pretty loud audience and they did
pretty well and we talked about it
yesterday that the person that zigs
while everybody zags is going to come
out ahead and I felt like I'm not going
to jump on the Vivek you know you know
hysteria train it's too early whatever
but you do win uh when you make
everybody else react the same way and
Trump used to do that all the time where
he would say something and the 20 people
on the stage would go
and so that's what Vivek was doing there
he would say something and everyone what
did he say I bought and paid for that
was the phrase and that just triggered
everybody and they all say the same
thing and that works to your advantage
because then everybody is focusing on
you and that's what was the most
interesting thing about this to me was
that the focus was on Vivek and not on
DeSantis DeSantis is supposed to be
number two right they didn't treat him
like that they treated Vivek like number
two I also think Trump Donald Trump not
being there ended up being a big plus
for these candidates because when you
have a personality that outsized that
bright then you can't see the other
people and so that game kind of like us
on the show with you yeah I was gonna
you know that was in my notes no but
they got it like if they got a strong
opening
um I think a lot of a few of the other
people probably did better uh but again
he seemed like he it goes to that thing
it's like if you're versed in in
Persuasion you will always have an edge
and you can kind of tell he's got it um
but um I would I think it's too early to
say who the Dem should be worried about
yeah right or even if the Dems are
worried about any of these people on
this stage yeah that might yeah I think
too early maybe the person that they're
worried about is actually not on the
station right I mean I I don't know so I
thought one of the interesting things
for me I had never actually been in a
debate room I've always either been in
the in the staff room the spin room or
on set getting ready to do analysis
afterwards so I got to be there and what
was interesting was when Vivek said that
you're all bought and paid for it wasn't
just the people on the stage that
reacted the I had never been in there
with where the audience was like how
dare you sir and that was and that was
like this moment and but they ebbed and
flowed like sometimes they cheered
sometimes I didn't and they cheered in
interesting ways what I thought really
one last night were issues in policy I
think people were hungry to hear what
actually would you do to make my life
better and go ahead I was going to ask
you who is the audience because the
aren't there are people who are GOP
donors RNC people unpaid for Dana behind
paper absolutely no but that's so I was
just wondering why they were so loud for
some people not loud but there was a
section everybody got a few seats for
everybody yeah
um the other thing is a Millions watch
great ratings more than anticipated so
what I really thought was interesting
was on America's Newsroom he had this
voter panel from whistle oh I saw that
so there's nine people for both days
before the debate and after the debate
so we were able to talk to them and hear
and the consensus for them was there was
a lot of people that their hearts might
have been with Vivek but their heads
were with DeSantis right and Haley and
that was their consensus they although
one of them Gerard he loves Tim Scott
and he was solidified on Tim Scott after
that
um they also sort of like Doug burgum
but they said but maybe he could be
something else in the government the
other thing is is that the voter panel
they had some young people and the young
people tend to really like Vivek but all
of them said but he's too polarizing
he's energizing but he probably couldn't
win and what's interesting about being
in Wisconsin that's where we'll be a
year from now or 11 months from now for
the RNC convention is Wisconsin is a
must win for the Republicans
so I asked all of them who here thinks
that any of these candidates could they
beat Biden in 2024 and they felt like
certainly that this is a field that they
have a lot of pride in okay and now the
Democrat takeaway was what do you fear
any of these people quaking in my boots
um no I found it really interesting I'm
glad that we're actually in season now
versus talking about like oh in a few
months we'll get to see now what's
happening and I think that that's really
important for the American people I
think the fact that Donald Trump wasn't
there was an advantage for them to be
able to at least it took about 45
minutes for them to start talking about
him and obviously was important and I'm
glad that Brett and Martha asked them
about you know how they're responding to
the indictments if he gets convicted Etc
um but this guy is up 30 40 points in
the primary I don't I did not see any
credible threat to Donald Trump winning
the primary here I did see a lot of
people who are talking about their
records and I thought it was fascinating
that five of the eight were governed
so they have real executive experience
to talk about they can discuss how they
brought down the debt I love that Chris
Christie and I'm just going to say
Democrats love Chris Christie for this
but talking about how he governed a blue
State and how he was able to get that
done
um I think that that's important too on
the Vivek front
um I did think that he and Nikki Haley
seemed like the winners to me and that's
been confirmed by the polling right
afterwards I thought it was very strange
that he started off by copying Barack
Obama so that line about the skinny guy
with a funny name that's what Barack
Obama said when he accepted that a uh
the nomination at the DNC why would you
copy someone as your introduction to the
world and not only copy someone copy a
Democrat and copy the most popular demo
would you eat plagiarists yeah
remember when Melania copied Michelle
Obama touche
no no one's into that thank you Kirsten
for laughing okay so I thought that that
was strange and I do think that as time
goes on lots of this is bubbling up with
Vivek these little pieces of like the
911 comments and the audio's been
released that he was you know he took a
Soros funded scholarship he was already
a millionaire when he took the money to
go to law school which seems pretty
deceitful I think people are going to
start digging into him on the Nikki
Haley front oh if someone gives you a
scholarship and you have a million
dollars in the bank you don't get two
million dollars you don't take it my
understanding is that you weren't
supposed to get it if you could actually
afford to oh oh so he's not worthy of
the scholarship
well there are scholarships that are
based on marriages need there's need
versus Merit correct so he took a need
one who knows it's not like he put his
you checked off a box that wasn't
authentic on his phone here we go yes
Elizabeth Warren said that she was
Native American okay
um I enjoyed Nikki Haley I do think and
I felt this way similarly even during
the Amy Coney Barrett confirmation where
she's obviously not my political cup of
tea but I do think seeing a woman up
there is just fundamentally exciting I
thought you did a great job she was the
only realistic person yeah you go yeah
you go girl oh stop it no you stop no
you stop it no you stop it it's great on
foreign
advertisers take it away all right hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else